largas filas en polonia que recuerdan la
época del socialismo esta es la
situación en la que se encuentran buena
parte de los polacos que dependen del
carbón para encender la calefacción son
ricos o bartz parte samán jorge está
bien
bota acampar dormir en el auto comer no
hay tienda aquí
no puedes moverte tienes que estar
pendiente de tu lugar recuerdo los
tiempos comunistas no me pasó por la
cabeza que pudiéramos vivir algo peor
en la mira lubezki acampan cientos de
personas esperando su turno para
abastecerse de este mineral al menos
unos 3.8 millones de hogares dependen
del combustible para resguardarse del
invierno los administradores de la mina
deben tomar medidas para controlar las
ventas destruidos lanzamos un punto para
pequeños compradores de carbón hasta 6
toneladas pero también hay que mencionar
los trámites hemos introducido una serie
de medidas para evitar situaciones en
las que las personas venían acá tomaban
un lugar en la cola y lo vendían o
intercambiaban el carbón ilegalmente a
jandro mat polonia es un gran productor
de carbón sin embargo el utilizado en
los hogares polacos era importado de
rusia la razón sus mejores condiciones
para el uso doméstico pero desde la
invasión ucrania más escaso y su precio
ha aumentado por las sanciones europeas
como el esquí las minas del país venden
la mayor parte de su producción a las
centrales eléctricas transacción que les
ofrecen más ventajas económicas que
comerciar con particulares el pasado año
en otro contexto geopolítico los
yacimientos tan sólo vendieron el 1% de
su producto de manera individual